do you remember the first time you saw
some random player go super saiyan in a
tournament or when a team you never
heard of one at all and then just kind
of disappeared you know what I'm talking
about those moments when a player or a
team surpass their limits for just one
incredible tournament and then they
didn't do it again so today we want to
honor those overachievers those players
and teams who flew so high for one
amazing tournament and then came back
down to earth here are the top 10
overachievers
in eSports there's just something
special about ninjas in pyjamas and IEM
Oakland and that's where we're kicking
off our list
they blew past everyone's expectations
in Oakland in 2016 and then they did it
again in 2017
[Applause]
and I be Kopacz imagine Oakland an
incredible story
and I defend that Oakland title nip was
on a decline in the years after their
major win in 2014 despite several roster
changes by 2016
nip were nothing but a middling csgo
team heading into I am Oakland in 2016
they were huge underdogs with
powerhouses like SK gaming and a straw
lucinda tendance but the Swedish old
guard shocked the world with a
performance reminiscent of their early
days winning I am Oakland and the best
part he says they randomly did it again
the following year feeding phase in the
finals forest is the one with the M 480
he'll pick baby that old pool Kerrigan's
attention tries to swing it they're just
fine
total climber from an IP carrying of all
the kills he likes because he goes back
to court he was gonna wait for this one
[Applause]
if we're never able to recreate their
Oakland successes anywhere else making
these two tournament victories a
pleasant anomaly for veteran csgo fans
the Swedes have done it a step towards
their former glory with new blood in the
roster taking our ninth spot we have the
legend of buzu fanatics ad carry in 2013
during the first year of EU LCS reckless
was too young to compete so until he
turned 17 fnatic needed to field a
stand-in for their ad carry role enter
buzu into [ __ ] was buried up RNA is
going too deep here he's gonna go down
push you gets the kill Jerry has to
flash away where's the snowball you are
not leaving
Jerry's down it's a double kill for
fortunately that's gonna be portion he
went he was actually being kicked into
ok with the hook
he's on mine he's gonna try and get in
there they want to get the damage up
towards me thing Peck a comes in should
finish him off one boy it does it but
now the backing is gonna get taken down
the silver bolt comes in two halves gets
himself a kill pushing tries to turn
this on the rain the number of French
armies coming there the power gets used
out Pashu is safe on fanatic whose you
won his first EU LCS split that summer
and made it to the semi-finals of the
2013 World Championship zhonya's
hourglass but sadly that is where poo
shoe story ends the ad carry stopped
playing competitively shortly after he
was dropped from fnatic whose short time
in the league saw him reach highs that
he'd never reached before and has never
hit again hey remember croman don't
worry nobody does but us which is why
the number 8 spot on our list is the
time that back in 2018 Cronin surprised
everyone as olofmeister stand-in on
phase
thanks to Olaf's break from pro play
chroman got the chance to play for a
tier 1 team in phase it was the
opportunity of a lifetime and chroman
rose to the occasion 10k per rain chrome
instead the valves are they're in a
great position here and that's what you
want to do dick Roman sure they've got
pistols but you want to win this round
how are you gonna do that get one kill
drop down towards lower and buy some
time here another kill for him a bit of
a miss job there but he stays alive
might be able to get another and look at
him go 3 big round over and he ticked up
twist as well solid from chroman during
Coleman's one-month stint on phase the
team won ESL one Belo Horizonte and made
it to the semi-finals of ESL one cologne
and snaps back with speed to immediately
take outs Maria behind him coffee as
well water his coffin he's got glories
looking for the ACE to pull it off the
standing stands up god I think Romans
pulled off the impossible time although
he hasn't done anything notable since
then crowman showed that he has the
potential for greatness during that
incredible month get this man a contract
forget this stand in [ __ ] he's
earned it
number 7 on our list is one of the
greatest underdog stories league of
legends has ever seen before south korea
monopolized the world championship for
five consecutive years one team from
Taiwan humbled beautiful beautiful play
by torchlight grab yourselves gonna get
up can they take side as well they do
[Applause]
the Taipei assassins entered the league
of legends of 2012 World Championships
as Taiwan's first seed but TPA weren't
one of the favorites to win the
tournament between international
powerhouses like world elite CLG EU
moscowfive and azubu frost TPA were a
dark one but they blew the rest of the
world away
despite qualifying for the 2014 World
Championship TPA never found major
international success ever again
TPA overachieved in 2012 but hey no one
can ever take away their dope world
skins taking six on our list is gambit
shocking 2017 pgl krakow major win
picture this
your Zeus and Navi kicks you after four
years of service people are saying
you're not good enough you're washed so
how do you get back at them
well I winning a major of course only
some of the boss Bo finds that now that
both feet they'll both be together at
Red's got a heavy we cook response I'm
just gonna go for the wall thank you
can't afford to because deuces popping
out a lemon for gambit CT side done kits
for steel kits for steel who's the one
with one HP but juice is gonna sit on
top of it this will be the round
we'll get their 13th round with the
addition of Zeus
gambit found their one shot at being
number one
sadly in camp it's time at the top was
short-lived
since Zeus will have the team to rejoin
not be right after the major will always
have the day that Zeus told off Meister
how he really feels I just say all of
mice then I'll Oreo and number five we
have digital chaos as unbelievable run
to the ti six Grand Finals DC were on
nobody's radar heading into TI they were
a ragtag group of players who've been
kicked by their former teams I have I
had a team that I finally achieved some
great goals with so I got these these
guys and we formed a team together and
now I'm here again knocked down to the
loser's bracket early in the tournament
vici faced a steep mountain to climb but
the underdogs found win after win
putting together an incredible loser's
bracket run that nobody expected
the digital cash
zero again a home and the Cinderella
story continues as DC will move on after
beating the Chinese juggernaut evil DC
found themselves in the grand finals of
Ti even beating out the defending
champions to make it there
[Applause]
although they weren't able to close the
deal and when the tournament VC's run
was not only incredible but also net the
team over three million dollars sadly
that's where DC story ends the team
broke up way before they could run it
back at CI 7 while the org still exists
as Kaos eSports Club the lineup the
captured fans hearts is long gone there
are few moments in eSports more
heartwarming than mana Rd surprising the
world with his Capcom Cup 2017 win
bursting onto the scene in 2017 Menna Rd
earned himself a spot in Capcom Cup
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Menna Rd went on to win the tournament
beating reigning Evo champion Toki doe
the man who tossed him into the loser's
bracket in the grand finals story but
despite his incredible inspirational
story
Mehmet hasn't made that much noise in
the fgc since his past two years of
competitive results have been average
making his freshman Capcom Cup victory
all the more special third on our list
is had a phenom Cinderella run at the
2016 of Austin a major this great scheme
came out of nowhere
beating team secret and Team Liquid to
qualify for the Boston major but how do
finem didn't just stop at qualifying for
the tournament
newbie LGD digital chaos had fit him
blew past them all making it all the way
to the Boston major grand
finals
[Applause]
is so happy
[Applause]
I've seen from him I need around saga
one step ahead terry gilliam fire
[Applause]
go to the grand finals and though they
might have lost to og they closed out
their one and only moment in the
spotlight with a legendary back door
[Applause]
despite a lack of success in the years
after the major ad finem second-place
finish stands as one of the craziest
tournament runs in dota history
League of Legends people tend to focus
on the major regions but sometimes a
team pops out from nowhere grabbing the
attention of viewers around the world
and no team did it better than Albus NOx
Luna at the 2016 World Championship as a
wild-card team from the CIS humba stocks
were the last team on anybody's radar
especially considering the group they
were seated in but they quickly got the
world's attention a little early Bowie
shot his load too soon
darshan it's down 6 a Sportster run for
his life look at that accelerated shot
bars it's a double kill for Kira they're
pushing CLG the Lee sin exploit a
miracle get shock wave but that's only
one target ego stay off the cue
slows down Smurfs good ol t no you take
that away how did that work
there's prey gonna still chase him down
traps ladybug crash oh my god the line
and brace go rip up a snail to sit
around Braille it gets up makiura
flushes in an extra spider on a satin
paint
Albus knocks advance to the
quarterfinals alongside the rocks Tigers
booting both MSI runners up CLG and
back-to-back EU LCS champs g2 out of
Worlds
they may not have made it past the
quarterfinals or found any success after
their Cinderella run at Worlds
but he'll miss Knox gave the world's
best teams a reality check emerging
regions are not to be taken lightly
because if you're not careful they might
knock your favourite LCS champions out
of worlds all I want to say is that hey
guys we are from wild car and they have
told you before being underdog doesn't
mean being a loser on set so taking the
number one spot on this list is a team
that well it's a team that no one's
talked about in a while but way back in
2018
they put North America on the top of
csgo we're talking about none other than
cloud 9 and their historic 2018 major
win don't get me wrong the 2018
iteration of c9 were a great team but
that cloud 9 roster was never really in
the list of teams you'd expect to win a
major but somehow they did it oh drop
top man shuts down caddy and now he's
got Intex bushy
close range is automatic for the mp9
look at the footage double-checking the
brother [ __ ] your image
[Applause]
stewey
[Applause]
haha and not only did they make history
they gave us one of the greatest major
Grand Finals the game has ever seen
something no counter-strike event is
likely to forget anytime soon wait
[Applause]
a job
but there is a reason why they're number
one on this list they haven't won a
single tournament since that major in
other words they fell off a cliff
cloud9 went from being one of the best
teams in the world to not even being the
best team in na making them esports
greatest overachiever I don't really
have much words to say as you know I'm
not crying you're crying stop yeah I
mean not much to say I can't really say
too much I'm just super part of the boys
and as a first major playoff you know
appearance it's uh it's amazing sorry
[Applause]
you know I think it's unfair to call
some of these guys like one-hit wonders
or something they could win another
tournament look at me people said that I
would never host top ten again and Here
I am you can't get rid of me I'm sick
I'm [ __ ] done